yeah i was just thinking it's
especially fun to be here at the seminar
i think i used to help organize this
seminar back in 2014
so it's nice to be back but yeah so i'm
going to be sharing
some of my work today specifically three
studies
from some of my phd thesis work but
before i dive into that i'm just gonna
give some some
broader context uh for uh all of the
the things that i do in my work um so i
want to start by unpacking some of the
terms in that really
long title uh the first one being
marginalization
so the definition of marginalization
that i use
is that it is a dynamic process where
people are removed
from the center and are pushed to the
periphery of a dominant social group
and this happens through the designation
of
power and resources
and importance it tells us who is being
prioritized in a given space
and very often marginalization happens
along lines of identity
so some of the protected class
identities are on the screen things like
gender and race citizenship
language body and our relationship with
marginalization and privilege is context
dependent
so everyone who's here in this virtual
space together likely experiences
different contexts of both
marginalization and privilege
and these things can change over time
they can change over the course of your
life
or they can also change over the course
of the day depending on what context
you're entering into
and the intersectional nature of
identity means that
the unique combinations of identity that
we occupy
give rise to unique experiences
and one particular context of
marginalization is technology
uh in some uh descriptions of technology
we were sort of given this promise
of equity and objectivity and instead
many of us are likely familiar with some
of these headlines on the screen
uh the countless stories of the ways
that technology
differentially affects and treats people
from minority groups
it is the status quo for technology to
embed
enact and perpetuate marginalization
and one of the consequences of that
marginalization
is uncertainty again uncertainty is
something that we all experience
uh but overwhelming uncertainty can be
incredibly harmful
uh to mental and even physical
well-being marginalization
tends to increase the uh magnitude
of the uncertainty we experience it
means that there are more regular and
frequent experiences
uh with uncertainty uh in specific
instances so for example uh we take
something like a standardized test
you might have uncertainty about your
ability to remember the content
or to perform well but you might have
additional burdens that marginalization
might place on you like am i
representing my group well and what will
be the consequences of my poor
performance
for other people who might belong to the
same group as myself
marginalization also increases the
frequency
of uncertainty through unique
experiences such as those with things
like persistent bias
racism sexism other forms of prejudice
and these are embedded sort of in in our
everyday context in our everyday lives
and finally part of what makes all of
this so insidious is that it is
cumulative when we have marginalizing
experiences those negative
impacts build over time to create
again mental and emotional burdens
physical burdens and practical burdens
uh to well-being
uh so all of this taken together
presents some really interesting and
exciting opportunities to investigate
uh for research uh specifically
we can understand and dive deeper into
the ways that marginalization amplifies
uncertainty so we know that it does that
we don't know a lot about those specific
mechanics
we can look at the influence of social
technology and understand
how might it help in these situations
and how might it be harmful
and we can investigate how we can design
for better situations of empowerment in
coping with or reducing
that uncertainty that might be causing
harm
so i'm going to be talking about three
studies over the course of a
several years long project investigating
a specific instance
of marginalization and uncertainty
through
the care project the care project looks
at
interpersonal racism as a specific
instantiation of marginalization
so i'm going to walk through three
studies that demonstrate
qualitative and storytelling methodology
as well as participatory
design and game design as approaches
towards addressing
marginalization and empowerment so the
very first study
i began by looking at best practice in
this space
so for the remainder of the talk i just
want to provide a brief
content warning all of the research i'm
going to talk about deals with
interpersonal racism
which is of course a personal and a
sensitive topic
so i just encourage you um to take care
of your own needs first while you're in
the space if you need to step away for a
bit and come back or
pause and return you're more than
welcome to do so
uh so some additional context uh for
that phrase i used interpersonal racism
uh so what i mean by that is uh
experiences of racism that happen
between
individuals or groups of individuals so
that specific focus was necessary
because there's just so little
research in this space and i wanted to
get as concrete as possible
but it's important to understand that
definition in the context of a larger
framework of oppression
so some other forms of repression
include ideol ideological
uh institutional and internalized and
throughout the research you'll see
how it's really hard to separate all of
these concerns so i'll be sharing some
stories from participants later on and
you can see how these different forms
will touch on the work
even while i'm mostly having a
conversation about what interpersonal
racism looks like and how we can cope
with that
so to give some additional background in
my research i use
a critical race theory as a framing and
critical race theory tells us
that racism is an everyday experience we
can't treat it like it's a special thing
that only happens when we encounter
overt bigotry
instead modern racism is subtle it's
embedded in our everyday context
and it can be unintended while still
being incredibly harmful
and that subtle nature of modern racism
not knowing whether it was intended
or if it actually happened means that
uncertainty is often at the core
of experiencing racism
and finally as with other forms of
marginalization and uncertainty
experiencing racism frequently causes
long-term harm to
mental emotional and physical well-being
it can cause
hypertension long-term damage to heart
health as well as chronic anxiety
amongst a host of other negative
outcomes so this is something that's
affecting people
in a very real way on a daily basis
whether or not
they're experiencing overt forms of
racism
and while it's necessary to combat
racism and to engage in anti-racist
practice
acknowledging that it's pervasive means
we also need to devote
time and attention to the ways that we
can cope with and mitigate those
negative impacts
we're not going to get rid of this
tomorrow we need to make sure we're also
supporting people right now
today so
part of the reason why it's so
challenging to deal with racism is
because
while social support is known to be one
of the best ways of coping
with racism discussing racism is
incredibly difficult right it requires
us to be incredibly vulnerable
uh to speak about experiences that are
potentially traumatic
you have to find the right person to
speak to someone who's actually going to
provide
the support that helps that is necessary
and when we look at the social tools
that might facilitate that social
support
we find that they again amplify a lot of
the things that technology is already
amplifying when it comes to racial
disparity
specifically online spaces where you
might go to seek social support
entail specific risks of harassment and
hate speech when you are someone from a
racial minority background
so with that understanding of these
challenges and why this is an important
space to investigate my initial study in
this area
posed two specific questions the first
being
after experiencing racism what social
support
seeking do targets engage in already and
what motivates them to do so
and what are the specific opportunities
and barriers for the technology that we
have right now
in regards to supporting people who've
experienced racism
and this investigation takes on an
assets-based
design approach in hci we often talk
about
need finding and understanding what
problems a user might be facing
and instead this approach looks at
assets
uh people who experience racism have a
lot of strategies to cope with these
things that they're already using
to great effect how can we understand
what those assets actually
are and center those and bring them into
the design process
so in order to investigate those
questions with an assets-based approach
i conducted narrative episode interviews
with 14 adults who have
identified us experiencing racism we did
hour-long sessions with three parts
the narrative episode which is a
person-centric method that allows people
to have
as much agency and control as possible
in an interview context in choosing what
they might share
with a researcher followed up by
semi-structured interviews
about some of the topics we knew we
cared about specifically
around social and communication
technology and then conducted
a few surveys on those same topics
uh this paper was quite long there's a
lot of findings packed into it
and today in this talk i'm going to
highlight a couple key findings that
motivated
the rest of the work that continued
afterwards
so the first thing i want to share is
just the range of stories collected
during the process so we asked
participants to share as much as they
were willing to about their
experiences with racism and whatever
coping they engaged with afterwards
and across the 14 participants we
collected 52
discreet stories discreet stories being
stories that had specific contexts or
people involved
so saying someone a person in my lab
asked to touch my hair
last week would be a specific discreet
story but saying that bull
comments on my english all the time is
not a discrete story but it is still
included in our
uh analysis uh the stories range in both
practical and perceived intensity
uh and many of our participants shared
uh stories from childhood uh
even though we had prompted them to
think about things that happened in the
past two years
those stories from childhood very often
stick out prominently and they're
stories that people have already
processed and coped with and
narrativized to some extent
uh so the first result um i wanted to to
share um is related to this first
question
around what is it that's actually
getting people to seek support uh so we
know that support's important we know
that it's challenging
what is it that pushes them over that
edge to reach out to talk to someone
about their experiences
and we found that uncertainty was still
central to that emotional experience of
racism
having open-ended questions about those
experiences
pushes people to to go out and seek
sources
where they can resolve those things so
i'm going to share a very long quotation
from
study participants but i'll read it
aloud and highlight a couple of
important
components so this story was from a
participant who described
parking his car in his neighborhood he
did this on a regular basis on this hill
that overlooked the space
he had a long day and wanted to take a
moment to collect his thoughts
and one of his neighbors called the
police on him
and he uh the police approached the car
in full force with guns drawn it's a
very physically dangerous
situation that he was very fortunate to
be able to to leave safely
but he described all of these questions
that he had after the fact
um why me um there were so many other
people who did the same thing that i did
but no one else
ever had the cops called them i don't
know why it was that this happened it
didn't seem to happen afterwards he
watched that hill
for many nights after that fact uh and
even more troubling
uh he found out afterwards as he was
exiting that the neighbors who called
the police were the neighbors who
frequently babysit his daughter
so he described the story to me more
than a year after it had happened and he
still had
open-ended questions about why this
happened
again why me why that night what did i
do
and what can i do to continue to keep my
family safe and is my daughter
specifically is she safe with neighbors
who enacted
racist violence upon me uh so he did
engage in
a number of different kinds of social
meaning making in order to resolve this
uh reaching out to again someone who is
trusted who is likely to have had
similar experiences is a powerful way of
resolving that uncertainty
but it comes with a lot of risks if you
speak to the wrong person
it can create really damaging setbacks
to coping
specifically in validation by asking a
lot of questions about well what were
you doing
why were you there things like that can
be really damaging to that coping
process
so towards the second question uh how do
social technologies factor into this
entire process
i found largely that participants do not
use
uh mainstream social communication
technologies to talk about these issues
because there is a very earned mistrust
of social platforms
every participant either had first-hand
experience or had
a loved one who experienced harm because
of discussing their personal experiences
with prejudice or bias or racism online
it is emotionally laborious to explain
these kinds of stories on a public forum
and it comes with very legitimate risks
of things like doxxing and harassment
some participants were concerned that
they would lose future job opportunities
one participant was in law school and
said if i post online that i've
experienced racism
uh future employers might think that i'm
biased and that i won't be able to
to process any cases with people of
color and that was a very real concern
that came from
experiences of this person's colleagues
so all of all of these interviews
outlined a couple of specific challenges
that we can
address through design specifically that
overwhelming uncertainty
suffuses all of these experiences with
racism this is one of the main
experiences that we need to design for
when we're thinking about this space
and social connection the specific way
that it helps
is through meaning making through
resolving those uncertainties
but it's still a laborious process it
requires a lot of not only emotional
labor but very practical labor and just
explaining all these
stories over and over again again
right now there is a really big gap
between audiences
people of color largely feel that social
technology is not made for them at least
when it comes to
some of these necessary processes to
engage with social connection
so with the knowledge of those
challenges and some priorities we can
think about
we can progress into design work
so this next study i'm going to talk
about uses participatory design
to bring stakeholders into this process
and we're thinking about how to change
uh what social communication technology
might look like
so the first question i wanted to
investigate knowing that uncertainty
is core to the experience is to dive
deeper into what that emotional
experience actually is
and what it might look like so to answer
that
first question i used a interactive
vignette study method
for those of you who are unfamiliar
vignette studies are a method
that stem from practice in psychology
and they're using they use fiction to
elicit
feelings and perceptions about
hypothetical scenarios
uh so a more classic vignette study
might just ask you to read a story and
to make some judgments and assertions
about character in the story
uh but interactive fiction allows us to
do much more complex work when it comes
to sensitive topics and vignette studies
part of the reason this is so effective
is because fiction creates this
uh safe psychological distance right
even if you're reading a story about
something that you might have
experienced
you're reading about it from the
perspective of another character someone
else who might be experiencing that
and it makes it much more easy to engage
with
socially complex or difficult topics
this is a method that is also used in
clinical psychology and other sort of
therapeutic practice as well as
experimental psychology
so interactive fiction deepens vignette
studies by
taking on a more active role instead of
just reading a story on paper you're
actually engaging with the story
firsthand
interactive fiction stories are things
like choose your own adventure where you
as the character
are deciding what happens next uh
whether that's through dialogue trees or
other kind of more deep
interactive medium and it gives a lot
more agency
for the person who's experiencing that
vignette in deciding what happens next
uh so in order to implement these uh
vignettes i use
twine which is an open source tool for
interactive non-linear fiction
using web programming and some other
abilities there and
previous work has used twine to create
vignette experiments that look at things
like iterative decision making
this tool allows us to give dynamic
responses
to participants so we can actually lead
them along different paths depending on
what they're choosing
we can actually embed measures um
depending on what they select in the
story and actually look at that as a
form of research data
so the story that i wrote for the study
focused on racial microaggressions
so this vignette follows the story of a
college student who experiences a racial
microaggression
in a meeting uh the first person
perspective
allows me to study what it's like to
experience racism from a first person
perspective
without inflicting what i deem to be
unnecessary trauma
like a deception study might if we
wanted to again study these firsthand
experiences
and microaggressions um are particularly
useful to study in this context because
of their subtle nature
microaggressions um are much smaller
instances of racism
where again there might be unintended
harm being caused so that high degree of
uncertainty makes it ideal to
to study this research space
in the story again vignette users are
able to make their own choices
they play as the main character sam who
is a research assistant in the lab
some other main characters include
professor smith who is the
research supervisor for sam and dr avery
is a visiting professor
and they all have um sort of just a
coffee meeting
um where the lab is introduced to dr
avery
so in this vignette there are three
racial microaggressions that
take place back to back during that
introductory meeting
the three statements are your english is
so good
you're so articulate and where are you
from where are you really from
where are your parents from uh so again
these forms of racism
are often unintended they're usually
said with good intention
uh but for those uh in the space who've
heard these before
they are alienating uh forms of racism
um so each one of these targets people
from specific racial minority groups so
the reason we included three is to have
the greatest likelihood of someone who
was engaging in the study
recognizing at least one of these or
having potentially personally
experienced one of these so
for the measurements of the study we're
recording the decisions people make in
the vignette
how do they respond to uh this
microaggression who do they speak to
what do they do afterwards we also ask
some embedded questions in the vignette
while they're actually playing through
it so we pause
the different moments and ask them to
rate how they feel about different
characters or how they might be feeling
themselves
and we also conducted a post-vignette
study that looked at things like
immersion
uh some basic democratic
um so uh answer the second question this
is a study that had two parts uh the
second question we're interested in is
what kinds of design
can promote and empower uncertainty
reduction as a form of coping
so to do that we conducted a
foundational fiction
participatory design workshop so
participants who engaged in study they
did that interactive
fiction vignette at home on their own
and then they came into uh workshop
sessions with us
in groups following doing that at home
homework
so the foundational fiction uh workshop
is a method
that i developed with one of my
collaborators hillary carey
because while participatory design does
have methods for dealing with sensitive
topics
there weren't existing methods that
precisely did what was needed for this
study which is bringing a group of
strangers
into a design process for an incredibly
personal and sensitive topic which is of
course racism
so this method uses fiction
as a jumping off point to have a
conversation around
experiences with racism so when
participants come into the workshop
uh which takes place over two hours they
first
uh reconstruct the vignette so they've
all wrote it at home on their own they
come into the space
and they remember key moments they
decide what was important what happened
throughout the story
they then analyzed that story over
multiple rounds of analysis
they help us find what are the needs for
the person in the story what
might um what might be needed in this
specific experience
where are some pain points and where
some opportunities for design where can
we create tools that might make this
experience better for
sam the character uh and at a certain
point we start opening this up to say
you don't have to just answer this for
sam uh where might this relate to
moments in your own life where would you
like to see
technology make these situations easier
or better or promote
safer and more positive forms of coping
and then finally they move into ideation
spaces where they start
actually storyboarding and pitching
different ideas for what that technology
might look like
uh so we conducted six of these
workshops with 26 participants from the
pittsburgh area
and recruited them by asking whether
they had thoughts that they could share
about racist interactions
these were all again people who had
self-identified as having experienced
racism previously
and the largest representation of this
group were people who identified as
mixed-race individuals
so again here what we're measuring is
their recall of the narrative
was it actually meaningful enough for
them to remember what happened and
what of it did they identify as
important
we analyzed each of those needs pain
points and opportunities
and we did an analysis of their design
proposals to look at the underlying
themes
what features of technology do they
highlight as being important to these
processes
um how feasible are they and are they
related to uncertainty which is the
topic that we're interested in studying
uh so to just show you a few examples of
these storyboards from participants here
are
some of my favorite ones just to give
you a sense
of what they were talking about in the
sessions um
one of these is a smartwatch button for
racism where you have a little alert on
your phone
you click it and really loud alarms go
off in the room that you're in so you
can kind of do this covertly
to to signal that something
inappropriate is happening in the space
one person pitched an augmented reality
device
um so when you walked around you could
see a person's history of making
racist remarks wherever you went and the
image
on the far right is a little smart
speaker
that's your friends when you return home
you can talk about your experiences
and it tells you it's not your fault how
can i help make you feel better
uh and it has an essential oil diffuser
and it's all able to play music so it's
a
really fun device um so
to analyze all of these we did an
inductive thematic data analysis this is
just a picture
of me doing this analysis in person in
february right before we started going
on quarantine
and then eventually i had to translate
all of this to amiro board to do
online collaborative analysis which was
an interesting challenge that um she
worked out really well
uh so here is a list of all of the
themes that came
up when we were looking at all of these
design proposals of course these are
far more than i could possibly talk
about today so i just again want to
highlight
a few that are important to the final
study and design work that i'm going to
be presenting at the end
so the first theme uh focused on
um again this connection to uncertainty
uh specifically this theme highlighted
the importance of validation in these
processes and it aligns with that prior
work that shows that uncertainty and
meaning making are critical to this
coping process
so what this theme adds that
conversation is this idea that
reducing uncertainty is not just for the
person who is targeted by an experience
of interpersonal racism but it's also
for everyone else in the space
uh it's it's important to again for
participants to convey the sense that um
their feelings about this process aren't
enough that they need to call on some
kind of authoritative figure
in this case data that is able to to
validate their experiences
so to just share a couple of quotations
from participants uh we had one
participant who said
siri's listening all the time anyways it
would be cool if she also listened for
racist things
uh and another participant followed up
and said yeah then maybe she could say
something
she could speak up for you and say hey
that was racist she'll add it to her
file on you and say like hey did you
notice that you only ask
certain types of students where they're
from and again what this is proposing
is um not just this technology but it
also conveys this perception
of my participants which is that they
think that their technology is already
always listening and recording
regardless of their consent
and they propose a future where that
data is actually being used
for their own good and for something
that's actually useful for them
other participants proposed again
creating files on people assessing
language
uh to calculate the likelihood of future
racism and i'll i'll talk about this
more in depth later but i will say right
now
um my proposal is not that we ever
implement these things there are a lot
of considerations going on here
instead they're highlighting interesting
things about what participants
perceive their needs to be this next
theme takes that a step further
and it says once you know that
something's happening once the idea
that something racist is happening what
do you actually do
what steps do you take to protect
yourself or take care of yourself or
take
care of others in that moment and a lot
of the designs that were proposed in
this space
represent the first part of what is
referred to as an ouch oops protocol
an ouch used protocol is one where the
person who is harmed
has to acknowledge that harm out loud it
stops the conversations this is
something that is used
in discussion spaces and acknowledge
that they've been harmed and it gives
space for the person who enacted the
harm
to pause acknowledge that they did wrong
and apologize
uh so you can see there are a lot of
examples of what that might look like
here on the room again some of these are
very practical
some of them are very silly and
fantastical and something that we would
never want to see in actual practical
reality but there was this desire
expressed through these for technology
to take on that role
it's incredibly it creates a lot of
vulnerability to step up and say
hey that was inappropriate or that hurt
me or that was something that was
incredibly prejudiced to say it's risky
to call that out when it's happening
so participants proposed technologies
that could take on that vulnerability
and that heat and remove the focus and
the burden from targets
from always having to not only
experience these difficult situations
but then also do all of the work to
unpack that
in a given space and the final theme i
want to focus on today
is a bit of a different a totally
different perspective on what it might
look like to cope with these processes
and instead it looks at comfort it looks
at the emotional side of that experience
participants expressed that again the
emotional experience of uncertainty is
anxiety inducing and overwhelming
and what might it look like for my
technology to prioritize my well-being
in that way when it comes to these
experiences
so again i just want to highlight a
conversation that happened between
participants in the second workshop
as they were finalizing their their
ideas
so one participant proposed that you can
have an app that you talk to
it listens to all of your unfiltered
thoughts and it reflects back
why someone did something it can open a
recording you can let out your emotions
and then you can delete everything
afterwards so it goes away it's
just for the catharsis of it and another
participant iterated on that said yeah
you could have an ai that knows exactly
what to say to comfort you
depending on your personality or it
might just let you rant
and a third participant followed up and
said it could be catered to you no
matter the situation
it emulates actual friendship
uh so through this workshop we found a
couple of again interesting findings
that contribute to the space
of anti-racist technology design first
is just a methodological contribution
the foundational fixture a fiction
workshop was incredibly effective
in facilitating conversations around
future speculative design in a space
that is incredibly potentially sensitive
and vulnerable
for participants it creates a space that
is open for vulnerability again using
that psychological distancing
of the fiction but then creating moments
of validation
for participants as they discuss the
meaning of those stories and what they
took away from it
this study also contributes some
knowledge towards uh what is commonplace
understanding of modern technology
participants expressed a number of
perspectives on what their technology is
already actively doing
and how it is either prioritizing their
well-being or how it is
uh harming their well-being a lot of
that
rich perspective that you can read more
in the paper and finally it highlights
considerations
and themes in designing technology that
can empower uh coping with uncertainty
from interpersonal racism
uh specifically it highlights themes
around complex understanding of how
technology can amplify
mac depression but again as i
hinted at earlier these proposals are
not
solutions they represent
an ongoing and public discussion around
different kinds of technologies
but they don't necessarily take those
ideas and put them
in context so these are what are known
as naive fragile fictions
they help us highlight really
interesting trends and themes and
perspectives
but because they haven't been evaluating
context they are not
solutions to actually be implemented
so the workshop told us uh priorities
and themes
uh and the final study i'm going to
share with you today
shows us what it might look like to
actually see these in context
so for this final study we move more
deeply into design work
and take on a provo type of approach if
you're not familiar with provo types
they are provocative prototypes again
the goal here is not to make something
that should actually be
created in the wild but it's to make
some kind of actual
tangible artifact that illuminates the
tensions and contradictions within a
given practice
and it allows us to again place these
ideas and put them in actual context and
see what happens
when you put them in context so it has
roots in
critical design and critique but also
moves us into a generative space we're
actually making something
and understanding what that might look
like
so for this final study i again
used the foundational fiction vignette
to actually put
those design themes in context
so i rewrote the story and instead in
that moment
when they experienced their racial
microaggression participants have a
chance to use the technologies that were
proposed
in the storyboarding earlier so at the
very beginning of the story they see
this additional uh
priming that in the story they'll have a
chance to encounter
a futuristic fictional technology so in
the story we give participants the
chance to
use or not use the technology they're
not forced to that's up to them
we also give them many different options
of how they might use it
so i'm going to describe the three
prototypes so there is
many rounds of iteration and filtering
that we used to to reduce down which
of the storyboards went to move forward
uh that included evaluating whether or
not again they
directly addressed uncertainty uh
whether they were practical to write
into the vignettes
and whether or not they would tell us
something different about how
participants experience
racism and uncertainty so the first
provo type
is the racism alarm the racism alarm
combines multiple proposals and it
embodies that theme around
data validation and intervention in the
moments
it also serves some teaching purpose to
people who are
perpetrating the racist interaction
so it detects racist speech in public
spaces
when the racism alarm hears someone say
something racist it blares
really loudly in the space and it can
only be shut off when the person who
tripped it leans forward into the
microphone and says i'm sorry
it then silences and it prints out a
strip of paper with contextual
information
about the offense the second provo type
is a little bit more subtle the
smartwatch ally
embodies the data validation theme but
it also helps
more practically with what you should do
afterwards and how you might respond
so the smartwatch ally is described as
measuring stress signals such as your
pulse
and your voice and it offers advice for
how to respond in the moment
to a racist experience so it's described
as being
particularly designed for instance of
prejudice including racism sexism or
homophobia it offers to record the
conversation once it's been tripped
it offers to call your phone with a fake
phone call if you want to
exit the situation and step away and it
also offers to ping potential allies in
the space
who might step in for you it can also
give you advice
about how you might respond verbally to
this experience
and the final prototype the comfort
speaker embodies that
final comfort theme that i discussed
it's meant to be an advanced smart
speaker similar to the storyboard that i
showed earlier whose purpose is to help
with stress
so it has customizable personality
settings uh
it allows you to vent it offers to be a
listening ear
it can text or call people for you it
can play music
release your favorite scent or set
lighting in the room so all of the
different again proposals that we heard
around
designs that prioritize comfort
so in order to evaluate these three
provo types
we asked three questions first uh is
this method of putting provo types in an
interactive vignette even
effective can people meaningfully
understand and evaluate the designs that
they're seeing in the story
uh if that is true how do those designs
impact people's perception of racism in
the conversation
and finally how do the designs impact
people's emotional experience of the
conversation
so as i mentioned we embedded those
prototypes in the
vignettes and evaluated this with 42
adults from the united states
using amazon's mechanical turk and the
study has three conditions one for the
alarm one for the watch and one for the
speaker
so this is between design so
participants only saw
one of the the provo types
and again we again ran the vignettes
with all of its embedded questions and
did a post vignette
evaluative survey
the post vignette evaluative survey had
a couple of components
uh the first was just uh soliciting
design feedback from the participants
uh what did they like about it could
they describe what it actually does
what's their likelihood of actually
using it if it were to actually exist
we assessed their perception of racism
so we asked a number of different
impression questions of those specific
characters in the story
as well as some some grounding questions
so for example what is your impression
of dr avery and on a scale of one to
seven
do you believe that dr avery's comments
at the cafe demonstrate racial bias
uh and then we also ask questions around
their emotional experience
what emotions do they think uh the main
characters sam experienced during that
conversation at the cafe
on a scale of one to seven how strongly
would you rate that they felt those
emotions
uh and all of these questions come from
previous research
we did in the space those motions came
from some surveys we had done earlier to
understand what the the main emotions
people typically feel during experiences
with racism
uh so this was largely um it's a mix of
qualitative and quantitative data
analysis
for those open response fields such as
what was your impression of this
character we did inductive thematic
analysis and evaluative coding and then
did some non-parametric tests for the
quantitative
questions uh so
towards that first question again can
they actually meaningfully understand
these
uh yes they can it's actually pretty
effective uh so for example
um uh the participants describing the
watch said the watch is an app
it evaluates your pulse and possibly
your voice to detect your emotions and
then it sends you some advice when
you're in awkward or stressful
situations
and to describe the speaker one
participant said the speaker's purpose
is to relax
and calm people down by removing their
stress i think it would be nice to vent
and feel like there is someone who's
actually listening to what you have to
say
so describing quite a lot of detail
about what the actual features of these
are
and also responding a little bit to what
they like and didn't like about it
so what are their actual impressions of
these designs
how do participants feel about each of
these uh largely participants
really hated the racism alarm they felt
that the racism alarm
created a really socially awkward
situation that it actually made them
more vulnerable in those spaces and that
they had absolutely no agency when it
came to that they weren't able to
actually say
when they wanted it to trip or when they
didn't it was just putting them in a
really difficult situation
so one participant says i liked nothing
i think the alarm is way too sensitive
and it made the person feel
uncomfortable where he wasn't initially
so they didn't even think
that sam in that experience was
experiencing racism that was noticeable
another person said i would not want to
create a scene and a third participant
said i would eliminate this from
existence
and it's important to note we did not
make this the racism alarm up these are
direct adaptations from multiple
participants in the study and again you
can see
um it's putting it in context reveals
some of the the tensions between
what might be wanted and what works um
practically
uh responses to the smartwatch ally were
a bit more positive they felt that it
was useful but that it was distracting
uh there was a focus on helping with
that emotionally
difficult part of the experience but
there was a desire for
even more agency when it comes to using
this they still felt like it was going
to be awkward
that people might notice that you were
using the alarm and they would be
offended that your watch
called them racist because it's your
device and you're responsible for what
it does
um so they said um it could be really
helpful in determining
my own emotions maybe i don't know that
i'm stressed but having my watch tell me
i'm stressed might help me understand
why
my heart rate is elevated or why i'm
sweating uh another person said
it confirms that the other person's
being inappropriate not that you are
being too sensitive so again aligning
with some of those
um uh but again this third participant
mentioned
i would change the buzzing it feels like
it's awkward it's a loud telltale sign
i would want it to be silent and to just
update me afterwards
and then finally responses to the
comfort speaker were incredibly positive
uh people felt that it was relaxing it
was a good listener
um and it gave them a lot of agency for
when
and how to actually interact with it so
we have comments like i like that it
made me feel relaxed
um you know by infusing my favorite
scent uh they like that it wasn't overly
imposing or dictatorial
and a lot of the feedback said there
isn't anything that they would change
about it a lot of participants spent
some time pitching
additional features that it might have
but there wasn't anything about what it
was currently doing that they wanted to
alter
and towards the second question how do
the designs impact people's perception
of racism
a couple of interesting responses to
this so we did an evaluative coding
um of that data on the impression uh and
found
that um so we use professor smith as his
useful foil for comparison because
people don't tend to say that he was
racist
and here we might expect participants to
indicate that dr avery is prejudiced the
most in the alarm condition
but that wasn't necessarily the case
they weren't necessarily willing to make
a strong assessment about her character
again because of the subtle nature of
microaggressions
there is a resistance to calling someone
racist who might have said something
unintentionally biased
and it turns out that explicitly calling
out racism doesn't increase certainty so
one of the goals of these designs
was to make people feel more sure about
the nature of an experience
and instead we found that in every
design condition participants
significantly more strongly agreed that
dr avery was racist
racist compared to professor smith but
there was no difference across the
designs for how they evaluated
um both of these characters
so again uh you know through a one-way
anova we found there was
no strong difference here um
and instead um calling out
explicit racism with the alarm uh seemed
to have a backfiring
uh reaction uh and instead again
the watch seemed to do a much better job
at signaling to people that the comments
were inappropriate without
overly placing and uh interpretation on
that
uh so now running a little bit short on
time so
i'm gonna just really briefly comment on
the emotional experience
so we did find that um the emotional
experience of each of these provo types
was very different
so we're able to code these into a
valence and arousal mapping of emotions
so these are all the emotions that were
listed to participants about how they
might have felt
the different moments in the story and
largely saw that
alarm participants felt really negative
emotions
with mixed levels of arousal or
activation of their emotions
watch participants felt negative
emotions with high arousal and a little
bit
of positive ones um we were a bit
surprised to see
so many negative uh emotions during uh
the watch
prototype and then finally the speaker
tended to create more positive emotional
experiences with again mixed levels of
arousal
so i'm going to kind of quickly move
through the rest of these i'm happy to
answer more questions about this
afterwards
because i want to get to a little bit of
of where i'm headed with some of this
work in the future
so again we found that this method was
effective in
uh demonstrating these prototypes and
letting people actually use them
it helped us evaluate them and find out
really interesting tensions
in the design of these technologies even
while actually doing things that
similar participants had asked for but
again we found new priorities such as
agency when it comes to this type of
technology
so i want to spend the last a couple of
minutes really quickly it's just talking
about
where i see this work fitting into a
larger hci context and where i hope
it goes in the future so first
this work contributes to these ongoing
conversations
in the digital humanities and in ethnic
and cultural studies and information
studies
around how race diffuses our
interactions and the construction of our
technology
and this brings a specifically hci
perspective to those conversations
this work also demonstrates the ability
of games and interactive narrative as a
tool to facilitate conversations around
things that are incredibly sensitive
this work also directly contributes to
hci
uh it demonstrates some specific
considerations in the design of games
and other social technology
in creating anti-racist technology it
shows how
again games can be a specific part of
that the role of uncertainty in all
these experiences
and it contributes specific knowledge
about how black and indigenous people of
color
experience racism and cope with it in
csw relevant contexts
this work presents methodological
contributions for participatory design
for research and design methods for game
design methods
and design and evaluation of
design prototypes
finally as many of you know
i wrote a kai paper this past year with
my co-first authors angela and finda
and while it's not a part of this body
of research
this research informed very much how i
approached this work on critical race
theory for hci
um it's my work tackles a very specific
understanding of race but there is
a lot of room and a gigantic open agenda
for other scholars to engage in this
kind of work
uh within the field of hci uh as i'm
thinking about where i want to see this
moving forward i wanted to share
this quotation from andre brock jr in
his book distributed blackness and i
want to take this moment to
to reflect on on this body of my work um
and andre writes about how
focusing on racism as a frame for black
identity
is deterministic right it's important
for us
um to understand marginalization
i think that there is incredible power
in understanding how oppression is
enacted
so we can uncover those dynamics and how
we might resist them
that being said focusing solely on
trauma experiences or marginalizing and
oppressive experiences
as the experience of being a person of
color i think is
overly deterministic it's not the only
thing that we should be studying when it
comes to
race and technology so much of my future
work is moving in that direction
moving away from just focusing on
oppression
marginalization and instead centering
experiences of joy
how can we use games to deliver joyful
experiences that
might address oppression or might be
there to just uplift and empower
people of color i'm going to be
extending
my work on these participatory design
workshops in that direction
and finding other ways to incorporate
frameworks of joy
and cultural wealth into my anti-racist
work
so with that uh i'll wrap things up i
wanted to just say
that um this work is done with an
incredibly large amount of really
wonderful
collaborators and scholars uh without
whom i would absolutely not be able to
do this
was able to work with i believe over 40
students over the course of all this
work
who were just really incredible
collaborators so with that i
thank you for being here and i'm looking
forward to taking your questions
excellent thank you silent claps um
while folks are queuing up one that i
was wondering about
um you at one point in your talk
you said these are not solutions you use
the phrase that they're like naive
fragile fictions
um which makes a lot of sense uh
so of course the sort of the place where
my head went from there was
okay so if those aren't solutions
um and then there's the
of course the broader effort of you know
deconstructing
racism uh but like if we know that's
not the right angle and we know that we
already need to be doing the sort of
societal level work
where can we as designers and
technologies
we i don't think we'd ever call anything
a solution but like where would that
live what might it look like um and this
could just be a hunch i'm not asking for
like
pointing at a specific thing and saying
well that's the the closest thing i've
seen
but you know what characteristics might
it have how can i
as um someone who who wants to learn
from your expertise in this space
uh say look at it haven't
that's definitely a frag versus this
feels more like a a solution
yeah that's a really great question um
i think to me it just it just means
engaging with this in a much longer
process right so i
i wanted to start out with um asking
participants to to build naive fragile
fictions because
i view this as a space that's really i
thought we could start from a space that
was like
really blue sky what what would it look
like if you're
if your world with technology was better
or more empowered so i think that that's
i think that's a really powerful frame
to start from but right where
uh in respecting participants that's
understanding like they are an expert in
a lot of things that i'm not an expert
in right they're an expert in their own
experiences
and what they need and i think that
that's
you know calling it a naive fragile
fiction maybe is obfuscating some of
that right there's a lot of power in the
designs that were proposed
but what these participants are not
experts in is like actually
building some of these technologies um
and actually deploying them
in a real world scenario right they're
able to picture what would it look like
if i
um had a better experience when it came
to these things but like putting that
in a living breathing social world where
a lot of factors are coming into play is
really difficult so i mean i think
the provo type work is moving in that
direction right it's like once
you can imagine like taking all that
feedback i got from that evaluation
study and using it to iterate something
that you actually might want to build in
practice
and that took a lot of those themes and
put them into something practical but i
specifically chose things that were
incredibly exaggerated
to try to find out where those
boundaries were because it's again it's
such an open space that we need to
to start just very slowly narrowing in
on that
um so i think that's entirely possible
to like do the type of work i did with
the prototypes but try to make something
that
you would actually want to see um that
was just a methodological choice i made
because
there's a lot of room for innovation
here and i wanted to just see like what
would it look like to choose some of
these
ideas that are a little bit more
exaggerated
thanks yeah i'm thinking about
what it means to design technologies for
allyship for example
um you had a question
hi alexandra good to see you again
seems like you've been really productive
since i've seen you last this is amazing
work
and i got a whole phd yeah um
i was curious uh i thought this was
really exciting thinking about
how you could think about physical kind
of co-located interactions thinking
about
how you might lead people through these
design exercises uh i think there's a
lot of assumptions there about
shared visibility of the information
being presented to people that played
into
currency things were acceptable
solutions or acceptable ideations around
interventions
um what do you think would be some of
the things that would transfer or
challenges to taking these to online
settings uh
you know uh online communities chat sort
of situations
um where you may not have the same
assumptions that the same information is
being presented to all sides or same
visibility into what's happening
yeah that's a really great question um
building that
trust and making it a space that is
actually safe
whatever that might look like for the
participants was a huge part of the
consideration in
in developing that participatory design
method
um so yeah when we were in person um
even entering that space knowing that
we're all interested in anti-racist
design things like that
you can still see like participants were
really tentative to engage with each
other in the very beginning
and that process of reconstructing the
narrative gave them the chance to
validate each other even if that's what
we were calling it
name and i do think that a lot of that
would transfer to an online context
right like i mean
they were had the ability to physically
reconstruct it they all have pads of
sticky notes
with different colors to like build up
these layers of like what the story is
and what's actually happening here
i i don't think that would be that
difficult to translate online and like
seeing
what other people noticed in the story
was really important because like we
never
actually tell them as the researchers
like and we don't like highlight what
moment was racist but when they start
telling each other that they noticed
that it's
that's the moment where you see this
really big shift in the conversation
so i actually think that that would
translate pretty nicely um
in terms of the specific dynamics that
happened in the room a lot of that is
work that's on
the facilitator like myself and my
collaborator hillary we ran all the
workshops together
and we we write about that a little bit
more in this uh this whip that we
published on this method but a lot of it
is really being transparent about what
our role is right so it's like the same
thing that you do in a typical hci user
study right where you need to explain
like we're not evaluating here that's
not the point here the point is that
you're an expert
and i have a lot to gain from your
expertise
let's collaborate and work on this
together um so that's
more of like an attitudinal thing about
how i approach my work um i try to
maintain some transparency and
communication with my participants
the participants i interviewed in the
very first study i shared
i interviewed them in 2018 and i sent
them all
an email two weeks ago that was like hey
the work that we did together
i don't know if you remember me but the
work that we did together when you spent
an hour with me talking about
some of your most vulnerable experiences
it's published now
and it was given the best paper award
and you should feel
extraordinarily proud that i think that
the stories that you share
are really impacting people who think
about technology
um so a lot of that is just in the the
relationship building that i have
with my participants so it's some of the
work that they're doing with each other
but a lot of it's in the framing of how
i'm trying to communicate what my work
is for
and who it's for all right well then i
get to i get to ask my question
um so i was thinking about how we
teach hci and design
um we've as you mentioned sort of
take often this you know human-centered
perspective
we're starting with you identify
stakeholders
need finding etc
and this often centers the power of the
designer in the process
so hci has developed a bunch of
alternative methods that
try to either be more participatory or
not center the designer and they're in
their sort of structural position quite
so much i guess what i would love to get
your take on is having done
all of this work um
what should stay about how we teach
design
and what should change you know if if
you were to write
alexandra's intro to hci textbook
what what would be most noticeably
different
and essentially how should we be
teaching
ourselves you know here cs147 or its
follow-ons 247 etc
at stanford
yeah that's a really great question it's
funny you ask like say i mentioned your
institution at northeastern trying to
encourage more reflexive practice
right
did they consider their expertise to be
what do you consider your
responsibility to be
when it comes to your design work and
yours your research work
can you reflect on like all of the
things that you bring to the table when
you're
entering a design space with a
stakeholder
so mostly i'm just trying to get people
to reflect on their positions in the
world and how they relate to other
people
and what kinds of commitments they want
to make to the communities that they're
doing work for
so i think being really persistent with
that
um is the thing that i'm the most
interested
in encouraging people to do because i
think what follows from that is a lot of
other kinds of ethical practice and a
lot of other considerations but starting
from understanding like
what your actual roles and
responsibilities are and the space that
you occupy in relation to other people i
think that is a
really important starting ground for
those conversations